So do take your Bibles and turn with me to Ephesians chapter two.
We're going to be continuing in our series in the book of Ephesians, and we don't always do this,
but could you stand with me as we read God's word together? Ephesians chapter two, it's also
there on your worship guides. And so when you find it, just join us in standing and we'll
read this passage together. It says, Therefore remember that at one time you Gentiles in the flesh
called the uncircumcision by what is called the circumcision, which is made in the flesh by hands.
Remember that you were at the time, at that time, separated from Christ, alienated from the common
wealth of Israel, and strangers to the covenants of promise, having no hope and without God in
the world. But now in Christ Jesus, you who are once far off have been brought near by the blood of
Christ. For he himself is our peace, who has made us both one and has broken down in his flesh the
dividing wall of hostility by abolishing the law of commandments expressed in ordinances that he
might create in himself one new man in place of the two. So making peace and might reconcile us to
both to God in one body through the cross, thereby killing the hostility. And he came and
preached peace to you who are far off and peace to those who were near. For through him, we both
have access in one spirit to the Father. This is the word of the Lord. Let's let's pray.
Father, thank you so much for this access you have given us through Jesus by your spirits
to come to your throne of grace and ask for your help. And so Lord, we pray for your help now
as we come to your word together. Lord, we pray that you would speak for your servants are
listening. We pray all this in Jesus' name. Amen. Well, when our first child was born,
we would have been happy with a son or a daughter. But I was really hoping it was a son
only because if it was a daughter, we had no idea what we would have named her. It was a
surprise whether or not it's going to be a boy and a girl or a girl. And so we knew
the boy would be Elijah. And if it was a girl, she would not have a name at all. So I'm glad Elijah
showed up. We were more prepared the next next time's around. You know, when this nation was born
back on July the 4th, 1776, it was born without a name. And it didn't have a name until September
of that same year. And a few names had been thrown around people thought about, well,
maybe Columbia to kind of draw the Christopher Columbus connection. There was another name that
was suggested by Thomas Jefferson, a rather grandiose name, the Empire of Liberty. So you could be part
of the Empire of Liberty right now. Others thought, well, maybe New Britain, but then a lot of people
were like, no, let's separate ourselves as far as we can from Britain. And they eventually
decided upon and formally adopted the United States of America. And the reasoning for that was
clear. So you have these 13 colonies, but they are united as one country, the United States of America.
So that was a noble aspiration, a unity and diversity. But that is a hard one to live up to.
And you can look at the history of slavery or the Civil War or of the Jim Crow south and see
that unity and diversity hasn't always been lived out in practice. This morning we are going
to see where true unity in diversity is found. It is found in Jesus and the new humanity that he is
creating. And this new humanity transcends all national or ethnic or cultural identities.
This new humanity is most commonly referred to as the church. And the church is made up
from people of all different backgrounds, but we are united in Christ. So the Apostle Paul in the
second half of Ephesians chapter two kind of lays this out for us in kind of three sections in verses
11 to verse 22. So the first kind of section he talks about the division that once existed.
And he talks about what Christ did to bring that to an end and bind us together.
And then he talks about our identity as those who are now united in him. So we're going to
kind of look at those first two sections this morning and the next week we'll pick up and look at that
last one together. So what we're going to look at is the division that once existed
and what Christ has done to bring us together. And really that can be summarized by what we
read in verse 13. So let's read that again together. It says, but now in Christ Jesus,
you who were once far off have been brought near by the blood of Christ. So far off and
now brought near. So let's just take that as a simple outline then. Okay. Number one,
out of the two things we're going to look at, we were once far off. We were once far off. There was
a distance that existed between us and God. And it also existed between us and the people of God.
So Paul begins here in verse 11 by telling us twice to remember who we once were and the
distance that existed because of that. He says it twice, remember, remember. Now if I said that in
England right now, you'd immediately thought of something after I said remember, remember.
Exactly right. We got a Brit right here. Remember, remember the fifth of November. So that was
this past week. It was bonfire night, the fifth of November. We celebrated at our house for
sure. Had a bonfire together. And if you've not heard of bonfire night before, it's kind of
looking back to when the gunpowder plot was foiled. It was a time of serious division
in England. And there was a plot to blow up the houses of parliament and to kill King James I.
And right in the kind of 11th hour, one of the conspirators Guy Fawkes was discovered with
all these barrels of gunpowder. And so last minute the plot was foiled and they went on
to celebrate a bonfire night for years to come after that. All right. So it kind of harkens
back to a time of a division that took place. And then what was done to kind of keep that from
becoming an outright disaster. So here we're called to remember the division that once existed
and the state that we were in because of that before we came to know Christ. So it's important
for us to remember who we were before God saved us. So what is this division? It's the
division between the Jews and the Gentiles. All right. So in the Old Testament, you can read about
how God chose Abraham and his descendants to be his people. He made a covenant with them
and they then became the nation of Israel. And so the people of the world, while there were
many peoples could in one sense be divided in two, you had the Jews and the Gentiles.
But it wasn't that God chose the Jews because he didn't care about the rest of the world.
It was his plan from the beginning to bless the entire world through them. You see that in Genesis
chapter 12 and he calls Abraham. He says it through him and his descendants, all the world would be
blessed, all the families of the earth. But distinct groups of people have often have signs
that mark them out. So on a typical Saturday in Alabama, you might see people walking around
in crimson red kind of giving each other a sort of a knowing nod, right? You kind of know
who's in and out of that particular group that supports a particular team. And so there's a
particular identity marker that Paul draws our attention to here that the Jews had been given.
And that was that marker of circumcision. So he talks about the circumcision and the
uncircumcision. Right. So circumcision was a sign of the covenant, a sign of the covenant
relationship that God had with his people. It shows who was in and who was out. And many
of the Jews refer to themselves as the circumcision. It's another way of identifying
themselves as belonging and they refer to the Gentiles as the uncircumcision.
And when this was written, it was being used as a derogatory way to refer to people who were
outsiders. It was a kind of mark of pride to refer to yourself as belonging to the circumcision.
So instead of seeing the world as people to bless, many saw them as people to deride. They don't
belong to us. And that's a problem that we'll return to in a moment. But first, I want us to
see what it says about us who are Gentiles. So how it Paul particularly draws our attention
to how far this then shows us that we were from the blessings that come with belonging to the people
of God. While it's true that there were many Jews who were outwardly religious but didn't have a living
faith in God, they had some amazing privileges. So while my ancestors were probably out worshiping
sort of nature gods, you know, often the Bronze Age, you know, fashioning idols by their hands,
the one true and living God was making himself known to this people. What a privilege. Paul speaks of the
unique privileges of Israel in Romans chapter nine, verses four and five. So here's what he says. He says
they are Israelites. And to them belong the adoption, the glory, the covenants, the giving of the law,
the temple service, and the promises. The ancestors are theirs. And from them by physical descent
came the Messiah, who was God over all, praised forever. So when it kind of when it came to this
fountain of blessing that would go to all nations, they were way upstream. And we were way downstream.
They were around the things of God. And so what does that mean for us? Well, notice what we
were far from. So we were far off. If we're not part of this people, then what is then true of us?
Well, it says in verse 12, remember that you were at that time separated from Christ. So we were
far from Christ. The Israelites could look forward to their coming Messiah. God's King was going to
come and establish his eternal kingdom. We didn't have that hope to look forward to. Most of
the world hadn't even heard that there was going to be this Christ who would establish this eternal
kingdom. We were separated from him and all the blessings that would come from being in him from
knowing him. But not only that, we were far from, you might say citizenship by what he says next.
It says we were alienated from the commonwealth of Israel. Now there's been a lot of talk of
immigration over the past few months and the sense of like who should be in and who should be
out. Well, here it says we were alien, literally foreigners to the commonwealth, literally
citizens. The same word Paul uses later on in the chapter that's translated as citizens.
All right. So we were foreigners to the kingdom. We were outside. We did not have citizenship or
the unique blessings that came with that, with being part of the nation of Israel.
We were strangers to the covenants. We were outside of that covenant relationship that God had with his
people. We couldn't claim the promises that they had been given. We hadn't heard of those promises.
We were strangers to the covenants of promise. So he talks about the condition that that left us in.
Because of that distance, we were without hope and without God in the world. So if you
don't have those promises, what are you going to put your hope in? If you've not heard of the coming
Christ, well, who are you going to put your hope in? We were without God.
Central to the covenant was the fact that God's people could say he is our God.
And we are his people. There was their relationship with God himself. But that
wasn't the case for the rest of the world who had not heard of this God. They were without
him. Interestingly, this word without the two words without God are one word in the Greek. And
it's the word we get our word atheist from. Ah fails without God. Interestingly, when you read
about the history of Rome and the early Christians as as the church started to grow, they were often
referred to as atheists. So these Christians over here, they're atheists. The reason why is
because they rejected all of those Greco-Roman gods, right? So if you were part of that world
at the time, those Christians were the atheists because they rejected all of these other
gods. But here, Paul then flips this around. He says, yeah, you were worshiping all kinds of so
called gods, but you were totally without God. The true God.
But Paul does something interesting here that not only addresses Gentiles, but Jews as well.
So Gentiles are only Gentiles in the Jewish mind. In other words, if you're a Gentile,
you don't think about yourself as a Gentile. That's coming from a Jewish perspective looking
on the world around them. So yes, Paul is directly addressing Gentile believers, but he's doing it
in a way that clearly has something to say to Jewish believers as well. So where do we see this?
So you go back to verse 11. He talks about Gentiles as being Gentiles in the flesh,
or natural born Gentiles. So this opens the door up for another deeper spiritual reality to be true
at the same time. So this is who they are in the flesh, but it's possible for something else to be
true at the same time spiritually. It gets even more fascinating. He uses that same language
that he uses to refer to Gentiles in reference to circumcision. Notice at the end of verse
11, he talks about circumcision as being in the flesh. And then he even adds by hands made by hands
over and over in the Old Testament. That is the exact language that is used to talk about,
get this, the fashioning of idols, the same language here. Idols are made by hands. And now
he takes what is the sign of the covenant and says, well, remember, but that is made by hands in
the flesh. So this external sign carried out by human hands didn't necessarily reflect the condition
of someone's heart because knowing God isn't a matter of the flesh who we are naturally. It is a
matter of the heart. We'll say this more simply. It is possible to be near the things of God physically
and yet be far from him spiritually. Now this is true of who knows how many people,
especially here in the South who are near to the things of God physically,
hearing about the Lord, hearing about Jesus, hearing the gospel and yet being far from him
still spiritually. And one of the way that that manifests is the ungodly divisions that take
place in the church. It can even take place along racial lines. It is possible to be in the church
and yet separate from Christ and separate from the true spiritual people of God. This is my story.
Like so many, I was raised in church every Sunday. I dressed up in my Sunday best. I had my external
marker that I was I was part. I went to Sunday school. I went to Sunday morning service. We were
there Sunday night and then mid mid week. Of course, I went to Awana's and some of you
had grew up in the same thing. I memorized the Bible verses. I sang the hymns. I listened to
the sermons, but I didn't know God. I was so privileged, so near and yet so far away.
How about you? I must ask if that is you. Here's what God says to us in Isaiah 55,
6, seek the Lord while he may be found. Call upon him while he is near.
And if you're no longer far from him, it's good to remember how far you were before you came to know
him and praise him for what he has done for you. So let's look at that now. So we were far off.
Now it tells us what God has done for us to bring us near. But now, verse 15,
in Christ, you who are once far off have been brought near by the blood of Christ.
Now this is similar to what we saw at the start of the chapter in Ephesians 2.
There is in the pattern here. Remember, we saw who we were. We were dead in our sins.
And then it said, but God. And then afterwards it says, he made us alive together with Christ.
A similar thing happens here. We were once separated, far off, but now in Christ we've been brought near.
And there's another word that Paul uses to describe what happened. And it's a word that he uses
four times. And that's the word peace. Christ brings us peace. In the Andes mountains between
Chile and Argentina, there's a statue that is called Christ, the Redeemer of the Andes.
And it's there to commemorate the end of a conflict that once existed between Chile and Argentina.
It almost became an armed conflict. But there at the border now stands this statue of Christ.
And at his feet are these words, Sooner shall these mountains crumble into dust
than Chileans and Argentinians break the peace, which at the feet of Christ, the Redeemer,
they have sworn to maintain. So peace there at the foot of Christ. But the peace we're reading
about here is far greater. It isn't just an agreement that is made at the feet of Christ.
It is actually brought about by Christ himself. It isn't just the peace of Scripture isn't just
an ending of the hostility while kind of still maintaining a border, maintaining a distance.
It is an end of hostility, yes, but it's also a wholeness. It's a complete unity that is brought
about between once warring factions. So three things to know about the peace of Christ here.
The first thing is it says that Christ is our peace. He is our peace. You see that in verse 14.
So Jesus doesn't just command peaceful relationships between us and other people.
He doesn't just inspire peace. He is our peace. It's not long until Christmas. I've
already seen Christmas stuff going up. There's a Christmas verse that's a favorite of many. Isaiah
9.6 that we'll be hearing a few times, no doubt, over the next couple of months. Let me remind you
of what it says. It says, To us a child is born. It's a prediction of the coming Messiah.
For to us a child is born. To us a son is given. And the government shall be upon his
shoulder. And his name shall be called Wonderful Counselor, Mighty God, Everlasting
Father. And what's the final name of Jesus there? Prince of peace. It's who he is.
Before he left, he spoke to his disciples in John 14.27. He said, Peace I leave with you.
What what peace is this? My peace I give unto you. Peace flows from him. Ultimate peace is found
in Christ. So Christ is our peace. But notice also he makes peace. You see that at the ends
of verse 15, he came making peace. So the Christ who is our peace achieves peace. How does he do it?
Through his death on the cross. So through his death, he brings us near. Well, how near? We see
that the peace that he brings is reconciling us to God. So he reconciles us to God. So we were
once far from God, outsiders to his kingdom, even hostile, even enemies. But the king himself
comes to where we are. He suffers the death that we deserved to die. And in doing so, he brought
an end to the enmity that we had with God. But bringing the enmity to an end once again,
the peace that he brings wasn't just, okay, we're no longer enemies of God.
It's that he gives us access to God and reconciling us to God. He brings us to God himself. So
chapter two and verse 18, that last verse says, for through him, we both have access
in one spirit to the Father. He doesn't just say, I'm going to let you go. The hostility is over.
You're free to leave. He says, I'm going to bring you near. You have access to me. That's
the kind of peace Christ brings. He reconciles us to God, but also he reconciles us to one another.
If you've ever traveled abroad, you'll know that when you get to a lot of points of
immigration, there will be one line for citizens and another line for foreigners.
Well, this isn't the way we're brought near to God here. It isn't that there is a Jewish
lane and a Gentile lane. Notice it says that we were both reconciled to God in one body through the cross.
There's a one way of salvation over here and another over here. It's all through Christ. It isn't
that there are separate groups who happen to be reconciled through the same person.
Christ came to unite us also to one another in him. So we have the same way of salvation,
and we are also united to one another in Christ. So notice the degree of our peace,
Jew and Gentile, our wholeness, our unity. Chapter 2 and verse 14 says that Christ makes us both
one. So he takes the two, Jew and Gentile, and makes them one.
It says it again in chapter 2 and verse 15 that Christ came to create
one new man in place of the two. So Christ came to create this new humanity. This new humanity
is the church that is made up of Jew and Gentile alike, made up of people from every nation. These
ethnic and cultural differences still exist, but there's a deeper spiritual reality. We are
part of this same new humanity. We're part of the same people of God. So you see this being taught,
for example, not just in Scripture, but also in the early church. So the early church
father, Chrysostom, said this. He says, it is as though God took one statue of silver
and another statue of lead and put them into a forge and they came out a statue of gold.
Right, so the two, but now they're one new thing.
And notice that it was in place of the two. That's how far he goes here. It's in place of the two.
Now there are some who still want to maintain that there are kind of two separate people of
God, maintaining a kind of a really sharp distinction between Israel and the church.
But here, along with many other texts, it makes it clear that there was one people of God
in place of the two. The two streams of Israel and the Gentiles have now merged into one stream
in Christ. So Galatians chapter three, verse 28 says this. There is now no Jew or Greek for you
are all one in Christ Jesus. It says it another way in verse 14. Christ came to break down the
dividing wall of hostility there in verse 14. Now disclaimer, he may only be using this metaphorically
when he talks about this dividing wall of hostility as a way of talking about the law,
which we'll get to in a second. But there was actually a dividing wall of hostility that
existed around the temple in Jerusalem. They had built a wall around it. It separated the inner courts
from the outer court. And that court was called the court of the Gentiles. And that dividing wall
ensured that the Gentiles not only didn't get into the temple, but also they didn't get into
the immediate grounds around the temple, right? So they were kept at a distance because of this
dividing wall between the two. The first century Jewish historian Josephus wrote about this
dividing wall and how there'd be signs to keep people out. And years later, as in like,
there's a point in time in the 1800s and then another time in the 1900s where
people who were doing this excavation found a couple of these signs. And we can see exactly
what the signs said at the time. Here's what it said on the dividing wall. It said,
no foreigner may enter within the railing and enclosure around the sanctuary. Whoever is caught
will have himself to blame for his consequent death, right? So a wall of hostility, clearly.
But this wall definitely represented the deeper spiritual reality that Paul is pointing us to here.
That there was a time in which people were being excluded from God's presence and belonging
to his people because of their ethnicity or their national identity. Where that wall once
existed, it has now been brought down and replaced with peace. There's equal access to God, to all
who put their faith in Christ. Notice in verse 15, and then says, connected to you, he did this by
abolishing the law of commandments expressed in ordinances. So what does that mean? Well,
it doesn't mean that the law of the Old Testament is now useless. No, the New Testament repeatedly
affirms the goodness of the law. I mean, the moral law, the Ten Commandments shows us what it
really looks like to love God and to love our neighbors. It shows us that we fall short of God's
glory. It shows us our need of Christ. It points to his coming. While it still has a purpose,
there is another sense in which we are no longer under the law, because when Christ came into the
world, he perfectly fulfilled the law. He lived a perfect life. He died the death that we who were
condemned by the law should have died. And in his death, he established a new covenant.
In establishing the new covenant, he made the first one obsolete, that old covenant.
So let's put this simply. Here's what is being taught to us here. The people of God are no longer
marked out or bound by the observance of ceremonial laws like circumcision or food laws. That's not what
identifies us as being part of the people of God or not. So Galatians 6.15 says, for neither
circumcision counts for anything nor uncircumcision, but a new creation. That's the question. Have you
been made a new creation in Christ? That is what determines whether or not you belong to the people
of God, whether or not you have been brought into his new humanity. So what unites us isn't
being part of the same nation or the same ethnic group or those external markers that
demonstrate that. Our oneness is found in Christ because he's made peace through his death. So he
is our peace. He makes peace. And then finally, he preaches peace. You see that in verse 17. He came
and preached peace to those who were far off and peace to those who were near. So Jesus not only
achieves peace, he announces peace. In Isaiah 57, verse 19, we're told that the Lord God
proclaims peace to those who are far and peace to those who are near. That's exactly what Paul is
drawing out here as well. Do you remember the first thing that Jesus said to his disciples after his
resurrection in John's Gospel? He said, peace be with you. Peace. That was his first message. Peace.
So peace is presented as good news that is proclaimed in the world. How does Jesus bring
about his peace in the world? How is he going to create this new humanity? How is he going to bring
all of his people together through the preaching of the gospel of peace?
So how do we respond to this message of peace?
First of all, if you've not, please come to the God of peace. Whether you feel like you're
far or near, Christ proclaims peace to you. He stands ready to welcome you to himself
and welcome you into his people. It's a response to this message of peace. Come, no peace with God
through Christ. But also, if you've come, cultivate unity with other believers. Live in the peace
that is yours in Christ. You see, we're not just welcomed as individuals when we become Christians.
We are incorporated into a body. So Christ didn't bring us near. He didn't die to bring us near
so that we might then keep our distance from each other. He brought us near so that we might know
his peace in our life together in the church. So lean into that. Get around other believers.
Look to God together for his peace. But also remember the church is diverse. The Ephesians
needed to hear this, and so do we. So the peace of God, if we're responding to that, saying,
yes, that's what we want, that will mean honoring other churches that are different to us culturally
and how we speak about, say, other churches. If they're faithful to the gospel, we're part
of the same family. This will also mean here in this church being ready to welcome people from all
different cultural backgrounds into this church. But I'll take it even a step further. It will also
mean looking for ways to honor and serve people from other backgrounds. Because what can sometimes
happen is we can say, like, we would welcome anybody, but implicitly assume that it's on
them to integrate into our way of doing things. You see the difference? We want to be welcoming. We
want to be serving and honoring one another. Leaning into that. In his book, Building a Healthy
Multiethnic Church, author Mark Demas, compared everyone coming to church with their own preferences
and their own cultures as like coming to a family meal. So he says, imagine this family meal where
you've got a sort of grandma there and maybe an aunt and uncle who are there. And so the kids are there,
the parents are there, and they look around and where's the teenager? He's not come. So the dad goes
up the stairs and he finds the teenager and he says, well, we're eating, we're at the table,
why aren't you down here? And he says, it's meatloaf. I don't like meatloaf.
And the dad obviously tells him, no, you come right down now and come to the table.
It doesn't look, the point is it doesn't matter what's being served up, you know, it might be
meatloaf today, it might be pizza tomorrow. The point is we're gathered together as a family.
There might be preferences at the table. Of course there will be. We might like one style of music
or another style of music dressing this way or dressing that way. There'll be all sorts
of cultural things happening, but we're all at the same table as family. That is what is
and importance. We're united together at the Lord's table.
And just as we're finishing, let's invite other people to that table as well. Let's create some
space to say Christ proclaims his peace to you as well. Isaiah 52 says, how beautiful are the
feet of those who preach the gospel of peace. That's how he's preaching his message is through
us as we invite others to join us at his table. Let's pray together, shall we?
God, thank you so much for what you have done to bring peace. Lord, we were once so far from you.
Lord, we were cut off from you in our sin. Lord, we were deserving of your judgment.
But Lord, we thank you that Christ came into this world. He died in our place that we might know
peace with you, Father. And Lord, we thank you for the work of your spirit who draws us to you.
And Lord, I pray that you would help us to hear you proclaiming this message of peace to us.
Lord, that we would come to you and be reconciled to you. And Lord, in that,
Lord, we thank you that we're also reconciled to one another as well. Lord,
thank you for this new humanity you have created. Lord, thank you for the fact that we can know that
we belong to your people through faith in Christ. Thank you for your church. And I pray that you would
grow us together, help us to live out the peace that is ours in Jesus and to invite other people
into that. I pray all this in his name. Amen.